[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH: So today, we're honored
to welcome Christian Picciolini.
He has quite a story.
He's an Emmy award-winning
television producer,
a prolific public speaker,
and reformed extremist.
He's here today to talk about
his work as the co-founder
of Life After Hate--
a nonprofit helping people
disengaged from hate
and violent extremism.
He's also the author
of "Romantic Violence--
Memoirs of an
American Skinhead."
Christian's life
purpose is really born
from an ongoing
and a profound need
to atone for his grisly past
and to contribute to the greater
good.
He began the process
of rebuilding his life
after leaving violent far
right extremist groups
he was part of during
his youth, and he went on
to earn a degree in
international relations
from DePaul University and start
his own global entertainment
company.
He was appointed a member of
the Chicago Grammy Rock Music
Committee and a board
member of CIMMfest.
I always try to say that,
but I don't get it right--
Chicago International
Movies and Music Festival.
It's pretty awesome.
So Christian's an
appointed United Nations
affiliated ambassador
IChange Nations
and was honored with a
National Statesman Award.
He's also an associate for the
USC Pride Homegrown Violent
Extremism Program
that I think you might
be going into in your talk.
And most recently, Christian
won an Emmy award for directing
and producing ExitUSA's "There
Is Life After Hate" PSA,
and he's been nominated for
multiple regional awards.
And Christian's going to
be sticking around today
for the talk and after
the talk, and we'll
have copies of his book
"Romantic Violence"
available for $10
out in the lobby.
So for Googlers in
the audience, be
sure to think of any questions
you might have for Christian
during the Q&A. So now, please
give a warm Google welcome
to Christian Picciolini.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Hi, everybody.
I remember-- my wife
was sitting over there,
in case you didn't
know, but I remember
when I used to see--
every person who
worked at the Chicago office
could fit in this front row
here.
It's not quite
like that anymore.
Josh, thank you very
much for inviting me.
It's good to be back.
I want to tell you a
little bit about my story.
My journey here started
22 years ago in 1995
when I left the American
neo-Nazi skinhead movement
that I helped build.
I was 22 at the time,
but I had already
spent eight years, every one
of my formative teen years
from the time I was 14
years old, in America's
first neo-Nazi skinhead gang.
But before that, I was
a pretty normal kid--
Chachi, I guess, is right.
I came from an Italian
immigrant family
who came to the United
States in the mid '60s.
I had low self-esteem,
low self-confidence.
I liked to play sports.
I was just a normal teenage kid.
But because my parents
were immigrants,
they had to work
very long hours,
and they were gone at
their small business
that they started seven
days a week, 14 hours a day.
And I spent a lot
of time on my own.
In fact, I felt very lonely
and felt very abandoned
at a young age.
I didn't quite fit in
into the Italian community
where I was growing up.
And I didn't quite fit in
into the American community
because my family
really held onto kind
of the old-world ways, so it
never really crossed over.
So because of
that, I didn't have
a lot of friends growing up,
and I felt very marginalized.
And just like any
other teenager,
just like any other
human being really,
there were three
fundamental needs
that I was searching for--
identity, community,
and a sense of purpose.
And that's something that we
all search for at a young age,
typically.
One day, when I
was 14 years old,
and I was angry at my parents
and angry at the world,
I was standing in an alley
smoking a joint, and a car--
1968 Firebird-- came
roaring down the alley,
spitting up gravel and rocks,
and it stopped six inches
from me.
And a man with a shaved head
got out of the car and boots,
and nobody really
in America knew
what a skinhead was in 1987.
This was before Raldo got
his nose broken with a chair
and before they were
on Oprah Winfrey.
But this man came up to me,
and he grabbed the joint
from my mouth.
And he was 26 years old
at the time, and I was 14.
And he looked me in
the eyes and he said,
don't you know that that's what
the communists and the Jews
want you to do to
keep you docile?
I was 14.
I didn't really know
what a communist
was except for Ivan Drago in
my favorite "Rocky" movie.
I didn't know if I'd
met a Jewish person.
I wouldn't have
known by that point,
and I hardly knew what
the word docile meant.
But I was struck with
this man's charisma.
It seemed like he was the only
adult, at that time in my life,
that had given me a real reason
not to do something that would
harm me, whereas my
parents might say,
don't do that
because it's stupid,
or don't do that because
what will other people think
if they see you doing that?
Though I didn't understand
his logic because I didn't
understand politics
at 14 years old,
it seemed like he had an insight
that should be important to me,
and he drew me in into
this community, which
happened to be America's
first neo-Nazi skinhead
group, started on the
south side of Chicago.
Most people don't know that.
About two years after
I was recruited,
that man went to prison for
a series of very violent hate
crimes, with the last one being
against the female skinhead
that was part of our crew.
They saw her standing at a
bus stop with a black man,
and they went to her apartment,
and they kicked in her door,
and they pistol
whipped her until they
thought she was dead.
And then before they left, they
painted a swastika on her wall
with her own blood.
Luckily, for that,
they were arrested,
and he was sentenced
to 10 years in prison.
Unlucky for me, that left a
void in this organization.
By this time, I
was 16 years old.
I had learned how to recruit.
I had bought into the
ideology, which was very much
an "us against them" narrative.
It was always about blaming
somebody else for the problems
that existed in your life
versus taking accountability
for those problems and blaming
somebody else because it
was very easy to
blame the other--
the invisible other person.
And I started to teach
that to other people.
And when he went
to prison, there
was an opportunity for
me that changed my life.
I essentially stepped into
the role of leadership
of this group at 16 years old.
And I went from Chachi to this
guy pretty much overnight.
As part of my job to
recruit more young people,
I had to use fear tactics.
Our way of recruiting
people was to scare them,
to essentially tell them
that people were coming
into our neighborhoods
to steal, who were black,
who were Latino.
We would say things like
the Jews control the media
and finance systems
and entertainment.
We would say that immigrants
were coming to our country
and stealing jobs--
sound familiar?
Not much has changed
over the last 30 years,
and I'll get into that.
But I started to
recruit these people,
and I started to
affect their lives.
And for the first
time in my life,
I felt powerful in the
false sense of the word.
But I'd felt powerless my
whole life before that.
So for a 16-year-old kid
or even a 14-year-old kid,
to now be a part of
this very powerful--
perceived power-- community, it
really kind of changed my life.
And I started to
come out of my shell,
and I started to encourage young
people to go out and commit
acts of violence.
And what I realize now
that I didn't realize then
is that I really hated
myself, and what I was doing
was projecting my own
self-loathing onto other people
to relieve myself of that pain.
Unfortunately, it took me
many years to figure that out.
I had started to become
a regional leader
around that time.
I merged our small group, which
was the first into a larger
group called The Hammerskin
Nation, which today is still
the most violent and deadliest
skinhead organization on earth.
It is now all over the world.
And I also started a band
that was a white power band.
My goal with that was
to encourage people
through my lyrics and my
music to join our fight,
and it was propaganda in the
truest sense of the word.
And it was also our version
of fake news back then.
This was before the internet,
so I started to tell people,
through my lyrics, to
go out and commit acts
of violence, which they did.
I gave them propaganda as
education, which they learned.
And that kept them in
because what would happen
is they would give
up everything else
in their life that was important
to them to join this group.
And that was important
for us because we knew,
then, it was harder
to leave and harder
to go back because
they had abandoned
their original identity and
their original community,
and we gave that to
them in a new form.
But we also gave
them that purpose
that they were looking for.
But we would always try
to look for young people
who were marginalized
or vulnerable
or who had some sort of
a grievance or trauma
because they were looking for
answers, and they were angry.
And it was easy for us to
manufacture answers for them,
to spin something
into an answer that
was more palatable
for them so that they
would blame other people.
In 1991, the band that I
started to make this music
was the first band to travel
outside of the United States
within this genre to play
in a foreign country.
And this was in 1991
in Weimar, Germany.
And Weimar is this
beautiful city
that is in former East Germany.
It's produced composers and
artists and great thinkers,
and this was the first
time that I really
recognized the
consequences of my words
that I was saying onstage
because, after this concert,
the 4,000 skinheads that came
to the show from all over Europe
went out into this town, and
they essentially destroyed it.
They broke into shops,
and they broke windows.
They stole beer
from pubs, and they
went around the town essentially
beating up the townspeople, who
were white and German.
And I didn't quite understand
why we were doing that.
And I didn't quite
understand how
it made me feel that they were
doing that based on my words,
and it really allowed me to
have this internal discussion
with myself to really
try and understand
what I was accomplishing and
how I was influencing the world.
And I had a really
hard time with that.
And I started to question the
ideology that I was a part of.
I started to see that they were
broken people who were hurting
other people because
they were broken,
and that's when I
made the connection
about me feeling broken
and hating myself
and then projecting
that onto other people.
And then something happened--
changed my life again.
When I came home from
Germany, I met a girl,
and we fell in love--
not her, somebody else.
And we had our child, and I was
19 years old when we first got
married and had our
first child and then 21
when we had our second son.
And it challenged that idea
of identity and community
and purpose.
I had gone from a skinhead
leader to a father.
My community priorities
shifted from the one
I had built around me to the
family I was now creating.
And my purpose began to shift.
It was about supporting my
family and keeping them safe
and providing for
them and not bringing
in the ideology that
I was a part of,
and that was an
important key for me
because I started to
ask myself, if I'm
passionate about this,
why is it that I'm not
bringing my family into it?
And I realized, at that
point, that it was not
something I wanted them involved
in because it was dangerous.
I had started to
question my ideology,
and I'd started to meet people
that challenged my narrative.
So to support my family,
I opened a record store.
I still wasn't ready
or brave enough
to leave behind that
community and that identity
because I had really
abandoned everything else,
and my family was very new.
So I decided the
best way to find
a middle ground was
to get off the streets
and open a record store.
That way, I could
support my family.
That way, I could come
home in normal hours,
and I wouldn't be
putting myself in danger.
But the point of
opening the record store
was not just to sell music, it
was to sell white power music.
So I began importing CDs--
this was before the
internet-- from Europe.
And very, very quickly, it
became 75% of my gross revenue
at the store.
People were driving in from
California and New York
to buy this white power music
because I was the only store
in the US selling it.
Something else
happened at that time.
I became a little bit
greedy as an entrepreneur,
and I thought to myself,
why should I just take money
from my brothers and sisters
when I could be taking money
from the enemy as well?
So I started to sell punk rock,
and hip hop, and heavy metal.
And when the customers
came in to buy
that who were African-American
or Jewish or gay or Muslim,
at first, I was a
little standoffish.
I was happy to take their
money, but I didn't really
want to talk to them
or engage with them.
But they kept coming back,
and they knew who I was.
And I was confused why
they were supporting me.
And every time they came
back, the conversation
got to be a little
bit more personal.
And then they would
come back, and then I
started asking them questions.
And one day, a black
teenager came in,
and he had told me that his
mother had passed from cancer.
And suddenly, I was able
to relate with this person
because my mother had been
diagnosed with cancer.
And we connected
on a human level.
And then one day, a gay
couple came in with their son,
and it was obvious how
much they loved him,
and it was the same love
that I felt for my child.
And I began to realize that
we had more similarities
than differences, that I
had never in my life-- not
just the eight years that
I was involved-- but never
in my life had a
meaningful conversation
or interaction with
anybody who wasn't like me.
And because of my
store, I was now
having these meaningful
interactions with the people,
who, in my head, I had a
different vision of who
they were.
I believed the propaganda.
I believed the hate and the
lies and the scapegoating.
And now, suddenly, I
was meeting these people
for the first time, and
they showed me compassion.
They could have easily gone and
broken my windows at the store.
threatened my family or harmed
me, but they didn't.
Even know they knew who I
was, they kept coming back.
And I received compassion
from the people
that I least deserved it from
when I least deserved it.
And that really allowed me
to humanize them and realize
that we needed
each other, that we
had the same fundamental
needs of joy and love,
that we had the same emotions
of anger and sadness,
and that we really were
all pieces of a puzzle that
couldn't be built
without each other.
So I became embarrassed to
sell the white power music,
and I closed the
store, obviously,
because I couldn't
sustain it anymore
with it being 75% of my revenue.
And at that same moment,
when I closed my store,
my life fell apart.
I didn't have a job anymore,
so my livelihood was gone.
My wife and my children
left me because I
hadn't left the
movement quickly enough
and paid attention to them.
I didn't have a great
relationship with my parents,
and I had lost my whole
community that I had built.
So suddenly, I was without that
identity and that community
and a purpose.
And for the next five years,
I woke up every morning
and I considered taking my
life because I wasn't sure
how to proceed.
I was treating other
people with respect.
I started to understand
our similarities,
but I was still miserable inside
because, for those five years,
I tried to outrun who I was.
I tried to make new friends,
wasn't very successful at that.
I moved, wore long sleeves
to cover my tattoos.
I was doing everything
I could to not face who
I was because I was afraid
of being judged just like I
judged other people until, one
day, at the end of that five
years, a friend of mine
came up to me, and she said,
you have to do something because
I don't want to lose you.
And I said, OK, well,
what do you suggest?
And she said, well, I
just started working
at this company called IBM.
You may have heard of them.
Why don't you apply
for a job there?
And I said, you're crazy.
I said, I'm like an ex-Nazi.
I'm covered in tattoos.
I went to six high schools.
I get kicked out of all of
them-- one of them twice.
I didn't go to university,
oh, and by the way,
I don't own a computer or
know how to use a computer.
Why would they hire me?
And she said, just go in
there for an interview.
See what happens, and just tell
them you're good with people.
I was like, yeah, OK, that's
what I'm going to tell them.
But I wrote my resume.
I lied on my resume.
And I went in,
and I got the job.
And that essentially
changed my life again
because now I had
found purpose again.
That gave me the ability
to find the confidence
to approach other people,
to seek forgiveness,
but also to find a way to
forgive myself because I
had been unable to do that.
And things started
to get better.
And the first day at IBM--
of course, they have
millions of customers--
where did they put me?
Back at my old high school
for a computer rollout--
the same high school I'd
been kicked out of twice.
That was my first day
at my first job at IBM.
I was terrified,
absolutely terrified.
I was a grown man who
was sweating and shaking,
and I couldn't find the words.
I was scared to walk
into the building
because I was
afraid that somebody
was going to say we know him.
He's got to go, and I
would lose that opportunity
for that first meaningful thing.
And of course, on that
first day, who walks by me
but the old black security
guard that I got in a fist fight
with that got me kicked
out for the second time?
I really didn't know
what to do then,
but I decided I had
to do something.
I knew I couldn't live in
that fear of being found
out or recognized and fired.
So I decided I was going to
chase him to the parking lot--
probably not the
smartest thing for a guy
that I got in a fist fight with.
But when I saw him
getting into his car,
I tapped him on the shoulder.
And this man, who normally
had this beautiful jolly
smile, when he turned
around and recognized me,
he took a step back
because he was afraid.
I couldn't think of what
to say except I'm sorry.
And I stuck out my
hand, and he shook it.
And we talked.
We embraced, may have
cried just a little bit.
It was a long time ago.
I'm not really sure.
I'm pretty sure we cried.
But after talking, he
made me make a promise,
and that promise was that I
would tell the world my story,
not because he thought, oh, kids
are going to become neo-Nazis.
You should tell them.
But because he recognized,
in my story, the story
of every young person,
who is vulnerable,
who is marginalized,
who can very easily find
a destructive path.
And I didn't really know what
he meant until a couple years
later, and I got a phone call in
2004 in the middle of the night
that my younger brother
had been shot and killed.
And then I knew that I had
to tell my story because he
was driving in a car
with some friends
in a neighborhood
he wasn't used to,
and some kids who are
scared of his skin color
decided that they were
going to shoot into the car.
And I knew that this wasn't
just something that affected me.
I knew then, at
this time, that I
wasn't the only one
with this problem,
that there were a lot
of lost young people
who needed to understand that
there was a more positive path.
So it took me 10 years to
do it, but eventually, I
wrote and published my book.
And in my book, I speak
to every young person.
While I use my own story,
and I tell my story,
I use the language
that I used at that age
because I want other
young people to be
able to relate to
what I went through,
and I think that I was
successful with that.
I also co-founded an
organization called
Life After Hate, and everybody
you see in this picture
here is a former
extremist, who has been out
for at least the
last 20 years and has
dedicated their lives
to helping dismantle
what they helped build.
For the last 22 years of my
life, mostly for the last 15,
I've been very actively
engaged in helping
people understand the
movement that I helped build.
I've consulted with
law enforcement
and done public speaking.
But most of all, what
I'm the most proud of
is helping people disengage
from hate and hate groups.
And we're able to
be successful doing
that because we really relate to
the people we're working with.
We were those people at
one point in our lives.
And what we do, when we work
with people, is we listen.
And we listen for
what I call potholes.
Potholes are the
things that appeared
in your path that happened to
you that eventually deviated
you onto a different path.
And when I listen
for potholes, I
hear about trauma and abuse,
poverty, lack of education,
mental illness.
And my job, then, becomes
to fill those potholes.
I work with partners
all over the country
to bring mental health
support, or job training,
or career guidance,
or education, even
tattoo removal for people, who
are in these movements, who
want to get out.
And I tell you that there
are so many people who
are stuck in these movements,
and even though they
may be questioning
their ideology,
they don't leave because they've
already abandoned everything
to go back to.
And they've spent time and
energy building this community
and this identity that starting
over is very, very difficult.
And I know because I was there.
So we try to be this
new community for them.
We've actually built a
network of over 200 people
that we've helped leave,
that have found us
after they've left.
And we provide a virtual
support system for them.
They can talk to each other
and understand each other.
And some days, in our
virtual community--
it's cat memes and
joking around--
and some days, it
gets really heavy,
where somebody will admit
for the first time to anybody
that they were sexually
abused at three years old,
or they'll come
online and tell us
that their son committed
suicide that morning.
And we rally.
We surround that person with
love and with compassion
and empathy, and they make it
because sometimes the things
that they're going through
because of their past--
it's not something
that they feel
comfortable talking about
with other people that
haven't experienced it.
I just want to talk a little
bit about the movement
now because it's changed
over the last 30 years.
What we used to think of
when we thought of the far
right extremist movement--
we think of skinheads
and Klan and militia.
And there are still people
out there like that.
We see them on the
news from time to time,
but it's different now.
The internet has changed things.
And this is an
important topic for me,
and I'm glad I'm speaking
to you about this
because, obviously, you are at
the fore of this thing called
the internet and connecting
people and information.
But what I've seen lately,
because of the internet,
is that so many vulnerable
young people, who
may be socially
awkward in real life,
are finding their identity
in their community
online in not the
greatest of places.
I'm seeing so much
propaganda and fake
news that is directing these
young people to a new narrative
because, let's face it, young
people, maybe even some of us,
were pretty disgruntled with
the way society is these days.
We question government.
We question law enforcement
on some of their tactics.
For young people,
they have a hard time
getting a job after college.
If they go to college,
they are saddled with debt.
They're really
looking for answers.
And unfortunately,
because of some
of the algorithms
that exist online,
it traps people in these
bubbles and puts them
down a rabbit hole.
Let's say, for instance,
you click on a story
or you Google a black-on-white
crime statistics.
Well, that may take you
to a fake news site,
and I know that y'all
are working on that,
and I'm glad that you guys are.
But this is important
because what happens
is, when they hit
that news story,
just like when you go to
Amazon, and you buy a product,
and it recommends Pampers
if you bought Huggies,
well, unfortunately, social
media also recommends
the same type of stories.
So you start going down this
rabbit hole of misinformation.
So what used to look like
this now looks like this.
And we might laugh
and say, oh, you know,
they're just teenage
girls being stupid.
They also look like this.
30 years ago, we
started this concept
of what's called
the alt-right today.
We recognized 30 years ago that
we were turning people away--
the average American racist--
because we had shaved heads
and waved swastika flags
and got tattoos.
So we thought, well, we need to
trade in our boots for suits.
We need to start wearing a tie
and going to college so we can
recruit on college campuses.
We need to get jobs and law
enforcement and run for office.
And it's getting
younger and younger,
and it manifests like this.
This is Dylann Roof, who walked
into a church in South Carolina
and murdered nine
innocent people because
of the color of their skin.
One day, he went and he
looked up black-on-white crime
statistics, and he was
led to a website that
is a white nationalist
or neo-Nazi website that
gave false information.
And he continued to go
down that rabbit hole,
and we all, unfortunately, know
what happened in that tragedy.
Alexandre Bissonnette--
Quebec City--
same situation--
murdered six people,
who were praying in a
mosque because of propaganda
and online misinformation.
James Jackson, just a couple
of weeks ago, in New York City,
went and murdered a
black man and tried
to stop interracial
relationships
because of the things
he was reading online.
Really happy that this one
was classified as terrorism,
and it's only the second
time that white extremism
has been classified as
terrorism in the United States.
The first one was the
Oklahoma City bombing
with Timothy McVeigh, who was an
avid attendee at Aryan Nations.
Without the resources of
calling it terrorism, I'm afraid
and I'm alarmed that we will
not be able to combat it
the way it needs to.
Since 9/11-- most of
you may not know this--
but more Americans have
been killed on US soil
by white extremists than by
any other foreign or domestic
terrorist group combined
by a factor of two,
yet we still don't
call it terrorism.
We hardly hear
about it on the news
unless it's a very
high-profile attack.
So what I decided to do,
because of all the influence
online for young
people, was that we
were going to start doing
interventions online.
So we launched an initiative
called ExitUSA.org,
and it's just a simple website.
It's just a contact
form, where people
can contact us confidentially
and without judgment
if they want help
leaving these groups.
As you can imagine,
sometimes it's
a dangerous thing
to do to leave.
They're also kind of testing
the waters to make sure
that they can trust
us because they're
afraid that we may be law
enforcement or turning them in.
And when we establish
that rapport with people,
we've had almost a
100% success rate
of helping people disengage.
I just want to tell
you a little bit--
actually, I what I
want to do is one
of the initiatives that
we launched online,
with the help of YouTube, that
I'm very, very proud of was--
and thanks, Josh, who
just left for a call.
That's what I want an Emmy
for, so I'm very proud of it.
This is a one-minute
PSA that I'd
love to show you
that we actually
ran on YouTube in front of hate
videos as a non-clickable ad,
so you couldn't remove the ad.
You had to watch it.
So we're essentially
making these people, who
were in this movement, watch
our video ad before they
watched the propaganda video.
Can we play that?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I was out there that night--
drunk, stupid, and
looking for a fight.
- When my mom found out I
was gay, I was 13 years old.
She threw me out the front
door, locking it behind her,
and that's the last
time I ever saw my mom.
- Someone yelled,
get the faggot.
I kicked him in the head
and watched it snap back.
- I remember looking
into those eyes.
The moment I saw him
again, I had to think,
can I forgive him?
- I spent half my life
thinking that I killed him.
I feared what I
didn't understand,
and that fear turned
to hate and violence.
Hate is like a cancer
that will eat you alive.
- Until there's nothing
left to forgive.
- If you or someone you
know is in a dark world
that hate takes you
to, we can help--
no judgment, just help.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: We were
very successful with that ad.
We ran it for only three weeks,
and the Wall Street Journal
actually ended up writing
an article about it
because, just in
those three weeks,
eight people reached out
to us that we've helped
disengage from these movements.
I just want to talk to you
a little bit about some
of the cases that
I'm seeing, and I
think this is also important.
This is Grace.
Grace is a 17-year-old
girl from Florida.
Her parents contacted me
through ExitUSA, and they said,
we're concerned
about our daughter.
She's making these
neo-Nazi propaganda videos.
They're horrifying, and she
has this 23-year-old boyfriend,
who lives in Idaho, who
essentially recruited
her and is writing the
scripts for these videos.
So I started to dig in.
I got a little information on
both the girl and her boyfriend
just so I could do some
research about what
I was getting myself into.
And I had an email and
a name and an address,
and I started to, for
about three weeks,
go really deep into a rabbit
hole, a really fascinating
rabbit hole.
What I discovered was that
this man was not only doing
this to her, but he was
doing it to 12 other girls
at the same time, some
as young as 14 years old.
He would become
their boyfriends.
He would only communicate
with them over the phone
or through email
or text message.
He would do Skype sessions
without the video,
and if he would
send a video, it was
obvious to me, when I looked at
it, that it was somebody else's
video that he had
stripped the audio
and recorded his own audio on.
I was able to do reverse
image searches on Google--
thank you very much--
to actually find out
which original pictures
he had used and
altered as his own.
So when I presented it to
this girl and her family,
what I discovered was that this
man was not a 23-year-old boy
from Idaho.
He was actually a 37-year-old
man from Moscow, Russia.
And the rest of his
group around him
that was also working
to spread propaganda
and a white nationalist
movement had
created over 100,000
social media profiles that
were using chatbots and
artificial intelligence
to put out misinformation,
but also to engage
in conversation with people.
Those accounts were
pro-Trump and also
very neo-Nazi at the same time.
They were fake accounts
that were just being--
technology was kind of
propagating these messages.
But they were also creating fake
Black Lives Matters accounts
and fake jihadist accounts
all with the purpose
of trying to put
out misinformation
against each other to
rile up everybody else.
I eventually turned over
that information to the FBI,
and when I met with the girl
and her parents, of course,
she didn't believe me because
this was her boyfriend,
so she leaked the
information to him.
And within an hour of me
leaving her house, 75 domain
names that I own
for my nonprofit,
my business, my mother's
business friends
were all hacked
by Russian malware
and pointed to porn
sites in Russia.
So our sites were shut
down for a couple of weeks.
I'm happy to say that I've
been working with Grace
for about seven months.
What I've done with her
is I've immersed her
into situations where she is
connecting with people that she
thought she hated.
I introduced her to a
96-year-old female Auschwitz
survivor, who is now her mentor.
And they're really good friends,
and they talk all the time.
They bonded over
playing the violin.
And it's those situations of
meeting the people that you
keep outside of
your social circle
and understanding them and
having a meaningful interaction
that really changes
people's perspective
because the ideology
is not a driver.
It's community.
It's identity.
It's that sense of purpose.
The ideology is just a tie
that binds them together
and gives them
license to be angry.
And I can tell you that
there are striking parallels
between why people
join ISIS, why
they join a white
nationalist movement,
or even why they join a gang.
And we're starting to
understand those connections,
that it really is not
necessarily driven
by ideology, that
it's actually the need
to belong to something
that makes them
vulnerable to the ideology.
I also want to tell
you about Darrell.
Darrell is a 31-year-old
man from Buffalo, New York.
He called me after
reading my book,
and he said I have
some questions.
And I said, OK, so I talked
to him for several weeks.
And then one day,
he told me that he
saw a Muslim man
praying in the park
when he was walking
with his daughter,
and all he wanted to do
was go up to that man
and kick him in the face when
he was on the ground praying.
And I said, OK, Darrell, well,
I'm flying to Buffalo tomorrow.
I don't know what you're doing,
but you're taking the day off
because we really need to talk.
And when I got there,
I asked him-- first
question I asked him
was, have you ever
met a Muslim person before?
He said, no, why would
I want to do that?
They're evil.
They're the enemy, and I don't
want to be anywhere near them.
I said, OK.
I excused myself.
I went to the bathroom.
I got out my phone, and I
googled the local mosque
in town.
And I was very quiet
in the bathroom,
and I got on my
phone, and I called.
And I said, imam, I have a
man here who is a Christian.
He would really love to learn
more about your religion.
Can I bring him over?
And he said, yes,
absolutely, bring him over.
I'd be happy to talk.
But I've only got 15 minutes.
I'm preparing for
a prayer service.
I said, OK, we'll be right over.
When we got there, we
had 10 minutes left.
And I knocked on the door,
and the imam answered.
He said, I've only
got 10 minutes,
but please come in and talk.
Well, three hours later, we left
the mosque after sitting down
and discussing religion and
talking about all the things
that were in this man's
head that he didn't--
it wasn't really connected
to any reality or logic
or rationale.
It wasn't long before they
were hugging and crying.
And I'm happy to say that now
Darrell goes to the mosque.
He's still a Christian,
but he volunteers there.
He helps set up chairs.
He cooks food for them.
And every Friday, he and
the imam go out for falafel.
They're now very,
very good friends,
and Darrell is
doing great as well.
Anybody can change.
What I'm trying to
say is that it's
the compassion and the empathy
that we give to those people
that we despise, that
we hate what they say,
that changes them.
Here's another example.
I don't know if you know
who Richard Spencer.
Is I'm sure you've
heard his name recently.
But I was giving a talk last
week in Whitefish, Montana,
in his hometown, and I sent him
a direct message on Twitter.
And I said, hey,
I'm in your town.
Let's grab a coffee.
And he happened to come
to my talk that night.
We spoke for two hours
afterwards, and we just talked.
We didn't battle ideologically.
I listened, and I listened
for those potholes.
And of course, I didn't
change Richard Spencer.
He still hates people.
He's still pushing
this alt-right agenda.
But I heard things
that will develop
into something else over time.
I heard things about those
voids, those potholes
in his life, and we've
agreed to meet again.
And I think a seed
has been planted.
At least, it's a good sign
that he gave the peace sign.
But I'm going to
continue talking to him.
While other people
want to punch him,
I can tell you that, when I was
18 years old, if somebody would
have punched me
because of my beliefs,
I probably would have come back
with something a little bit
more than a punch.
That doesn't change anybody.
I know our initial
reaction is to want
to eliminate and get rid of
the people who are dissenting
or say things that
we don't like,
and I'm here to tell
you that we need
to listen to them
despite how it makes
us feel because we
need to establish
that human connection again.
That's what helped
me change, and that's
what I believe will help
change people who are still
stuck in this movement.
I have a challenge for
you before we open it up
for questions.
I want you to leave
today, and when you leave,
I want you to do something.
And that's find
somebody who you think
doesn't deserve a kind word, and
I want you to give it to them--
or a kind action.
Show them compassion,
and see what happens.
See how you change, and
see how it changes them.
So I want you to go out there,
and my motto is kind of similar
to Google's-- the do no evil.
Mine is make good happen.
So I want you to go out
there, and I would love
for you to make good happen.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
And I think
there is a microphone there.
I don't know if we can
see the Dory questions on
here too if there's
any to come up.
But please, if you
have a question,
step up to the microphone.
And I'm happy to answer it.
And you can ask anything
as personal as you'd like,
and I promise to answer it
as honestly as possible.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Christian.
Great talk.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: What is your take
on this casual kind of racism
we're seeing that--
it's not exactly
punching in the face,
and it's not exactly dressing
up and going to college
as a racist or
running for office,
but it's like this kind
of lame, casual commenting
that I see even teens--
people we wouldn't assume to
be like this anymore-- doing?
What do you think about that,
or how do we change something
like that?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
First of all, I
think it was likely
always there, right?
It was probably dormant,
lived in the shadows,
and because of our political
climate, a lot of people
feel emboldened
saying those things
because, frankly, a lot
of people at the top
are saying very, very
similar things, right?
It's shaped to be a
little bit more palatable.
The messaging is a
little bit different,
but the mission is the same.
And I know because this
is the ball that we
started to roll 30 years ago.
And as far as the
casual comments,
I don't engage in them.
If I do engage, I engage in
a very compassionate way.
And it's hard for people
to shut down compassion.
However, if you
attack back, you're
going to see it just
go on and on and on,
and you'll see the
polarization go even wider.
Have honest conversations
with people.
Don't necessarily seriously
challenge their narrative.
Just be the message.
Be the message that
you want them to be.
So if you want them
to be understanding,
you have to show understanding.
If you want them to be
compassionate or empathetic,
that's something you
have to do first.
So that applies to
strangers, and I
think it applies
to people that they
might be family members that
we block on social media
sometimes.
But I think that we have to
establish that connection.
We have to start by
finding a middle ground
and then go out and talk about
all the difficult things.
But we have to have
these difficult and very
awkward conversations.
That's what's going
to connect us again.
Thank you, Sunni.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Wow, cray.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Thank you, I think.
AUDIENCE: Two questions--
one is about the five years,
right, that there weren't
a lot of details around.
I'm interested in-- I would
imagine there's relapses that
happen with this sort of thing.
I mean, so much of this is like
an addiction to substance abuse
and things of that nature.
So you talked about success
rates with your own people,
so I'm just curious what
happened to you personally
as well as what you see
with some of the people
that you're counseling.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: I've
never been asked that question.
That's really a good question.
AUDIENCE: The second question I
have is, within that time frame
too, and then as you
were coming out of this--
clearly, you deserve
all the credit
for getting yourself
out of where you were.
But I would imagine there
was someone that helped you.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
A lot of people.
AUDIENCE: And you didn't
really talk about that,
so if there's like one
person in particular-- just
to kind of understand
the support.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Sure.
First of all, those five
years were really dark.
I didn't have a steady job.
I didn't date.
I was still very adamant about
being there for my children
that I saw every weekend,
but other than that,
the rest of those five
days, I was deteriorating.
I got into drugs and
alcohol, and I was just
really not treating myself
with a whole lot of respect.
I was really ashamed of
what I had been through,
and I didn't think that
I deserved happiness.
So I was really
going out of my way
to be extra kind and extra
compassionate to other people,
but I was completely
ignoring myself.
The second question--
there were a lot of people.
It wasn't just one instance.
There were so many--
it was like I was
a pinball in a pinball machine.
It was like everybody
that I touched somehow
would impart on me
some sort of wisdom.
And I would take just like
a nugget from everybody,
and eventually I was able
to put them all together.
When I stopped the ego, when
I stopped thinking and started
feeling, that's really when
I connected with who I was
and with the innocence
that I lost at 14 years old
because I went from this
13 and 1/2 year old kid
to this 14-year-old
monster, essentially.
I was doing things that, not
only most adults don't do,
but most people wouldn't do.
So it was a very difficult time.
And leaving that, I didn't
have any relapses because one--
I couldn't go back.
Once I left, there's
no going back.
And two-- I knew how it made
me feel when I was there.
And even though I was going
through a miserable period,
and it was a very dark time,
I still felt some peace
that I wasn't involved in that.
And I knew I didn't want
to stir up those feelings
or go back into that confusion.
I knew, at that time, it was
not something I wanted to do.
And pretty quickly
after those five years,
I started the ball rolling
and doing some of the work
that I do now and
writing my book.
And writing my book, I
tell you, for 10 years--
really, it was pretty cathartic.
It was pretty therapeutic for
me to even think about some
of the things that I'd
forgotten about myself.
So it's almost like self-therapy
for me to write the book.
It was a tough time.
I'm glad I made it past that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for your talk.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask two questions.
One is, when you saw
really bad things happen
within your group--
for example, that girl that
got attacked and was a member--
how did you explain that
to yourself, like, OK, this
is right, and I want to be
the leader of this group,
or how do other people as well?
And then two-- I know
you're saying you first
got into contact with different
types of people in your record
store, but I come from a
very white Catholic country,
and I still feel like
I was always exposed
to so many different people.
And I'm just always
on the edge of--
some people, who are kind of
promoting these hate speeches,
at the same time, are hiring
people of different races
and stuff like this.
So I'm kind of confused as
to how that comes about.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Well,
it's a self-exclusion.
So even though you may--
I mean, I went to high
school with people
of all different colors.
And even though I had
access to these people,
I isolated myself from them.
I didn't want to engage with
them because I was afraid.
I never admitted it at that
time, but I was afraid.
And because I was 14
years old when I got in,
when I was younger,
I never really had
access to that
kind of diversity.
And certainly, when I was
14 to the time I was 22,
I kept myself out of that.
It was a choice that I made not
to engage with people until,
because I wanted to
be a good businessman
or because I was
greedy or whatever,
I was forced to engage
with these people.
And then I was like, ah, they
don't fit what's in my head.
They don't fit
what's in my heart.
My reality is not real.
And that's what helped
me build that bridge.
I forgot your other question.
What was your other question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I
was talking a lot.
But my first
question was around,
when there was acts
of violence, how
did you describe that to
yourself that that's OK,
or like anybody in these
types of groups, really?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Yeah,
well, we detached ourselves
from that too.
When we hurt somebody, we
weren't hurting a human
because we had
been so conditioned
and we conditioned each
other to think and feel
that the people we were
hurting were almost
like an inanimate object,
like a parasite or a cockroach
or a piece of paper that you
could crumple up and throw
away.
So that's how we
were able to deal
with what we were doing is we
completely detached ourselves.
It became us against the other,
and the other didn't matter.
All that mattered to
us was us because we
weren't able to humanize
them because we never
interacted with them.
It was almost like a
psychological cut-off,
like a wall that we had built.
And it wasn't until I had those
connections with people that I
realized I didn't want to hurt
them anymore, that I considered
them equal or, in many cases,
even better--
many cases, better than me.
AUDIENCE: I read
Christian's book.
I highly recommend reading it
because he does really detail
out where he was at
that moment in his life.
And it was one of the
most transformative books
I've ever read.
So I just really encourage
everyone to do so.
I had the opportunity to
interview Christian afterwards,
actually, for a book
that I'm writing.
And one thing that--
well, many, many
things stuck with me
after that conversation,
but one thing really
did in which he talked
about a lot of these people
within these organizations
and hate groups live
in a reality that's entirely
separate from our own,
especially in this world that
we live in here at Google,
where we're extremely blessed.
Can you speak a little
bit more about that,
especially because it's
likely that all of us
have an unconscious bias towards
some different even individual.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Sure.
Yeah, thank you for that.
It's good to see you again.
There are two
different realities,
and I think maybe
November after November,
we started to realize
that, that there
are these two sometimes very
separate tracks with not
a whole lot of bridges
that cross over,
and we tend to stay
in our comfort zones,
in our bubbles or
our silos and not
really cross over because
it makes us uncomfortable.
Know that, when we hear them
and think, it's ridiculous.
How can somebody think that?
They also think that about us.
Those are the two realities.
They think, how can
somebody want diversity?
That's white genocide.
The more people you allow
in that are not white,
the white people go away.
I mean, it's ridiculous, right?
But there are two very
distinct realities,
and we really need to--
if we ever hope to
eliminate some of this
or to change
peoples perspective,
we have to be willing
to build that bridge
and have very, very
uncomfortable discussions
with them.
And sometimes there
people that we love
and we think we
understand, but when
we hear something like that,
we think, who is that person?
I don't know that person.
Well, that person's
the same person.
They've just had something
appear in their path
that changed their direction
at some point-- that pothole.
Just listen, I think,
more than you speak.
People don't necessarily
like to be talked to.
They like to be heard.
So listen, but also
hold people accountable.
It's important to
do that, right?
If you hear something that you
know is not right or an action
that you clearly know is
hurting somebody else, including
that person, hold that
person accountable,
but also listen because that
will give you the clues on how
to build that bridge.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you
for what you're doing.
It's very powerful
and important.
What can we, as a society
and as individuals,
do to help those marginalized
teens or even younger?
Is there a way we can
engage with the youth
from an early age,
even elementary school,
to help teach them empathy and
tolerance to help prevent this?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Yeah,
well, that's a great question.
And I think that you
answered, partly,
your question is we really need
to be there for young people
as early as possible
from the day they're
born to not only
teach them empathy,
but to provide them
with opportunity
and to amplify their
passions, right?
I just said young people
don't like to be talked to.
They like to be heard.
We need to listen
to young people.
They have something
important to say.
They're passionate.
Their ideas may not
be completely formed.
They may not have the experience
that maybe some of us have,
but we need to be there
to amplify their passions,
to really listen to them
because I could to tell you,
if I was 14 years
old, and somebody
would have came
up to me and said,
hey, you're a really
good artist or you're
pretty good baseball player.
Let's find a way for
you to do those things
that you love to do.
I would have gone that way.
I mean, I wasn't
aspiring to be a hater.
I came from a family that
was the victim of racism when
they came to this country.
They were the
victims of prejudice.
It wasn't a part
of my upbringing.
I didn't even know
what racism was.
Let me just use kind of
a theory that I have.
I think that we should feed
young people, from the day
they're born, ethnic food--
different food instead
of chicken nuggets
and grilled cheese
sandwiches because maybe,
if they're not afraid
of diverse foods,
they won't grow up to be
afraid of diverse people.
I think fathers are so,
so important to young men
because what I'm seeing is that
so many of these young men that
are joining these movements are
doing that because they don't
have a connection
to their father,
because they're trying to be
something for their father.
There are a lot of
studies about masculinity
and the extremist movements
that make a lot, a lot of sense.
So there are lots
of things we can do.
We can do something
kind in a small way
that, if everybody just
does that extra kind
thing in their life, well,
that's billions of kind things
that happen every day
that are extra, right?
Hold the door.
Say hi to somebody.
Instead of looking
at your pixels,
look at eyes when you're
walking down the street.
There's so many
things that we can
do that really don't take a
lot of effort that I think
would really go a long way.
But opportunity for young
people is so important.
Instead of after
school day care,
maybe we should set up
after school incubators
for young people as
young as six years old
to start playing around with
things that may take them
down a better path.
SPEAKER 1: Let's have
this as the last question.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: OK.
AUDIENCE: So thank you,
Christian, always a pleasure
to listen to your talk.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In
speaking with people
that have very different
beliefs as you,
you said hold them
accountable, but you
don't want to be combative.
You know that they are
filled with fake facts,
but I know,
personally, I probably
don't know all of
the exact facts
unless I Google and
try to find three
other resources immediately.
So do you have any
techniques in how to listen
but also hold them accountable
without being confrontational
with your own gut
and moral compass?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Sure.
Well, I'll tell you about
my two-hour conversation
with Richard Spencer.
We hardly talked about ideology.
I asked him about his father.
I asked him about the kinds
of things that he likes to do,
and I listened.
And when he would drift
into that ideological space
and say something
that was a no-no,
I would tell them
and I would hold him
accountable for that by saying,
that's not something
that I believe in,
and I would appreciate it
if you didn't say that.
And you'd see kind of the
way he would talk shift,
and he would move on
to something else.
And he'd started to
go talk about how
he wanted to be a theater major,
and when we were walking out,
somebody had come up
to us and said, hey,
can I tell you how weird
it is that you guys are
both standing here, and
right next door, we're
doing a rehearsal for a
performance of Cabaret?
And his face lit
up, and we started
to talk about theater
and all these things.
And it's just hold
them accountable
in a non-confrontational
way, but still
keep that dialogue open.
It would be kind of like
talking to your child, right?
You wouldn't-- well, but you're
not going to go off and scream
at your kids and be angry
at them and tell them that
they're stupid and wrong or
whatever because that's not
the way you would
handle your kids.
It's almost like we have
to have those kid gloves,
but at the same time,
like, no, that's not right,
and then show them what is right
and have that conversation.
And they may not agree, and
it may take a long time,
but that's the way we're going
to get through to people.
I guarantee you, but arguing
is not the way to do it.
I don't know that any--
aside from a
structured debate, I
don't know that arguing
with anybody or going to war
or having a fight has ever
changed anybody's mind.
I just want to say
thank you so much.
Thank you to Josh for having me.
It was a real pleasure.
I'm happy to stick around and
talk to anybody afterwards.
It's really good to be here
again, and thank you so much.
Thank you, Google.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Thank you.